hey how you doing today doing great how
are you fine what's your name where you
from Eli Manning from okay New Jersey is
definitely in the house stop playing
with them we see the look describe it
for us today this is called the boring
look it's called the Dad look
um it's look where you're you're always
able to go play golf if you're at a last
minute someone calls you and say hey you
want to play golf I'm ready I'm dressed
for it absolutely so what's uh what's
this top from uh I don't know everybody
don't worry about it we still look you
see the shoe oh man
okay okay
shout out to your wife yeah if you give
anybody on silent hill what would it be
uh just always have a vest there's more
Pockets I like Pockets you know I've
always got things in my pocket cards
phones kids toys I like that that's a
good tip you know how would you describe
your style uh boring okay okay okay
what's your favorite meal uh favorite
meal is like some fried chicken or
barbecue stop playing with them yes sir
yes sir yes sir and what's the zodiac
sign uh Capricorn big Capricorn no cap
over here you see him Eli I think
somebody said Tom appreciate you